in just two weeks a number of
coronavirus cases has nearly doubled in
Texas to more than 200,000 by contrast
it's with nearly four months for the
state to get to its first 100,000 cases
Janet shamlian spoke to a nurse there
who fell ill with kovat and warns it
could happen to anyone I thought I was
invincible patty Peterson is a single
mom to two girls three-year-old Paisley
an eight year old Kaylin and helps raise
her ten year old niece Kenzie the 29
year old nurse tested positive for Kovan
June 26 she's been in a critical care
unit since last week and it hurts it
feels like someone's stabbing you in
your side when you try to inhale and you
haven't been able to see your daughters
have you no I haven't seen them since
July 2nd big facetiming everyday crying
mommy when you're coming home
you know Peterson doesn't know how or
where she got coronavirus but is now one
of almost 8700 Texans hospitalized with
the disease the problem is before that
curve really came back down the state
reopened we spoke to Harris County Judge
Lena Hidalgo in Houston
do you have any dialogue with the
governor right now about this we are
constantly in touch with his office and
my plea to the state has been I need the
authority to issue an enforceable stay
home order that's the only way we're
gonna stop ping-pong in between open and
closed they asked for more and more but
they do absolutely nothing governor Greg
Abbott Monday accused some local
officials are refusing to enforce his
executive orders including a statewide
masked mandate issued last week haven't
resisted that move for months whereas
Hildago first ordered a mask requirement
for Harris County in April now officials
from Houston to Austin fear their
hospitals could hit capacity in about
two weeks in the Rio Grande Valley
hospitals are already overwhelmed from
her hospital bed patty Peterson has this
message for skeptics you know everyone
fights it's blown out of proportion
until you're the person lean and CCU who
has no contact with anybody and you're
helpless
Patty is very sick but she's hopeful
she'll be back with those little girls
soon this morning were outside ben taub
Hospital in Houston which has had to
transfer some of its patients out as its
ICU neared capacity and this morning
Texas health officials say there could
be a potential spike again here later
this week as local communities report
the numbers from the July 4th holiday
Gale
oh boy Janet that news isn't good but
sure sure thank Patti for sharing her
story maybe people will listen to her
someone who's going through it